new game for working on Xbox one and ps4
and so it's gonna be that much better
with a first-grader game you need pro
skaters and obviously as the design team
you know we work with them to figure out
like what types of tricks match their
style
it comes down to authenticity or does
this trick look right as animation feel
right we bring that into the game but
still keep it a fun almost an RKG style
game that people expect on this
franchise
process of getting scanned here it's a
it's fun they have this big machine that
goes around your whole face and it's
just shining lights and you feel like
you're getting abducted by an alien or
something basically what we're doing is
using photons bouncing off the skin of
the person so it's kind of like going to
the dentist and getting an x-ray but
unless radiation
the process is cool I actually get
excited to see how it scans every little
bit of your face
and spun me around and got all pictures
of my face made me do happy emotion sad
emotion angry emotion this is cool as
hell I like winning this like big light
sphere kind of something out of like a
movie I was trying to look I was like
well there's a camera there there there
there are those cameras everywhere I
walked over and looked on the computer
and it's like a perfect every detail my
head right there like 10 seconds
everyone is a snowflake so if you make
sure that we get every detail that we
can then we always try to recreate the
feeling of the old pro skaters we're
huge fans of the series
with online multiplayer you're basically
a net virtual oasis with different
people and you're gonna have an online
skate community one of the big things
that we brought to this game that we
think is little revolutionary you always
play multiplayer it really is about a
skatepark experience you know when
people go to a skate park they don't
necessarily go there with any objectives
in mind they just want to go skating and
we thought that that was a really great
way to bring in multiplayer really it's
the first time this skate park
experience has ever been done in a
skateboarding game and we're super proud
to get that in there it's a lot cooler
than just shooting each other
you got to keep making the animations
look as realistic as possible
for example jaws making sure you really
land the way that you do the way that
jaw is done it's really important to
capture those nuances
to be honest I'm still doing most of
those tricks that I used to do so it's
really fun to see him on the new
consoles our interaction with Tony Hawk
who was extremely involved in French as
he loves video games he's worked on this
more than anyone else so he wants to
make sure that our games can switch it
to the skating community and most
importantly that's fun it will let's
make a pro skater game for 2015